[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right first up with a voice let's
check it out there's the voice we all
know the show the voice and then I
looked at the info button what it says
turn it on and it says celebrity judges
suddenly realize they're facing the
wrong direction
fascinating then there's si si si si as
on and look what the info button says it
says murders are solved in a crime lab
that's lit like a strip club that's one
of my favorite things about that yeah
here we go the Real Housewives of
Atlanta watching The Real Housewives of
Atlanta and I push the info button and
this is what it says see if you can
guess which one is Tyler Perry here we
go ultimate survival Alaska it's a good
show ultimate survival Alaska I checked
the info button and it says rugged
citizens travel miles to avoid Sarah
Palin
yeah I check that our own show I checked
out Conan yeah there it is and I looked
at the info button that was curious and
it said if you like the Kardashians
check out these giant asses Hot in
Cleveland Hot in Cleveland a very
popular show and I pushed the info
button and it says porn for Korean War
veterans yeah why shouldn't they be
happy locked up abroad we checked out
locked up abroad and look what it says
so when you push the info button it says
just when you thought it was safe to
travel to Kazakhstan with cocaine in
your Bible he was convinced it was
savory I'm sorry I was misled seriously
just give us your buck cocaine yeah
there he is later talking about oh he's
really upset okay American Horror Story
American Horror Story and check out what
the info button has to say never before
has a show worked so hard to confuse
your erections
yeah I know look at the local news the
local news was on and I checked out the
info button and look what it says
moderately attractive people tell us
stories we learned on the internet seven
hours ago
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally check this out fashion
police with Joan Rivers yep let's check
out the info button says celebrities are
mocked by a doll made from bogus
[Applause]
[Music]